I bring to you Johnny
Knoxville I'm glad to be here steo thank
you for having me again your previous
episode on our Wild Ride podcast is by
far in a way the most viewed episode
that we ever did and all it was was you
sitting down for me to talk at you the
whole time and tell you your
stories Emily's like what happens on his
podcast I'm like I just listen to him
talk it's fine
yeah since then it's been important to
me to grow to uh improve my
conversational etiquette do you think
you have improved I believe I really
genuinely have okay do you not I
[Music]
do I mean I think so I've been here what
three minutes and I've said three words
so I think he's done much
better I feel my face turning red